So as you all know, I'm voting for Bernie
in the democratic primary.
This is not a partisan story.
I will be voting for Bernie.
This is not an attack on Bernie.
I'm going to vote for Bernie in the Massachusetts
democratic primary.
I am not attacking or supporting any candidate
with this story, but the entire Bernie Bloomberg
heart health story that has been developing
over the last 48 hours is really, really bad
and here's the the, the way it's been going
down.
Both Michael Bloomberg and Bernie Sanders
are close to 80 years old.
They both have had heart issues.
Bernie Sanders had a heart attack last year.
Michael Bloomberg had a one or two stents
placed about 2025 years ago.
They should both release their full medical
records, period.
This doesn't have anything to do with who's
better on healthcare or who's better on stop
and frisk or who's more or less racially sensitive.
This has nothing to do with that.
Okay?
Bernie said he'd releases full records.
Then he backtracked, put out three doctor's
letters and says, that's all that we're going
to put out.
There are Bernie staffers attacking Bloomberg's
heart health with myth statements and it's
toxic and terrible.
So let's start there.
Bernie's national press secretary, Brianna
joy gray yesterday on CNN.
Listen to this.
She likens the Bernie health records requests
to birtherism, which is bonkers and then incorrectly
States that Michael Bloomberg has had heart
attacks.
I don't think we will release any more medical
records.
I have those three letters from the doctors
that Senator Sanders was talking about.
There's, there's nothing in him other than
the doctor saying that he's fit.
He had a heart attack.
Yeah.
Well you have a heart attack in the fall.
Do you think the American people deserve to
know more about his health going forward?
I think that the American people deserve to
know exactly as much as every other candidate
has released in this race currently and historically.
And what you're seeing right now is really
reminiscent of some of the kind of smear or
kind of a skepticism campaigns that have been
run against a lot of different candidates
in the past.
I'm questioning where they're from, um, aspects
of their, uh, um, their, their lineage, et
cetera, et cetera.
And it's really telling, given that men have
the same concern is being demonstrated for
Michael Bloomberg who's the same age as Bernie
Sanders, who has suffered heart attacks in
the past.
And what we're seeing is a kind of, um,
so she says, Michael Bloomberg has suffered
heart attacks in the past, plural.
And that's not true.
Michael Bloomberg has not had any heart attacks.
It's just not true.
It doesn't mean Bloomberg's a better candidate.
Bloomberg still imploded at yesterday's debate,
none of that changes.
But Bloomberg had a stent put in for a blocked
artery 20 or 25 years ago.
Now, Bernie's press secretary later corrected
and said she misspoke after being called out
saying, quote, I misspoke when I said Bloomberg
had a heart attack.
Rather he underwent the same stent procedure
as Bernie.
Bernie released three detailed medical reports
in December, just like the other candidates.
I am finding this to be pretty crazy.
Okay.
The, when Trump says I released the transcript,
he didn't, he released, you know, a piece
of it.
When Briana joy grace has Bernie released
three medical reports, they are doctors letters,
which Democrats previously widely said when
Trump released them, they were not sufficient.
We've just got to be consistent guys.
Okay.
Bernie promised his full record and then backtracked,
asked.
Uh, it is a very reasonable ask.
Given Bernie's a age and given Bernie's recent
heart attack, it is completely and totally
reasonable look up life expectancy for white
born in the United States.
Bloomberg has had stents put in demanding
the same of Michael Bloomberg is perfectly
reasonable.
Pete booted judge during the debate yesterday
said he'd be willing to undergo a physical
or whatever.
This is not about Pete Buddha judge, although
we should have the records from everybody.
Um, we just need transparency on this issue.
I don't think it's like birtherism.
I don't think it's a dirty trick.
I plan to vote for Bernie in Massachusetts,
but he promised it.
He's nearly 80 he had a heart attack and he
should release actual full medical records,
not just some doctors letters.
A Biden has had brain surgery.
He's nearly 80 we should know everything there
is to know about Biden's health situation.
There is no question that cynical actors can
weaponize this health thing.
It's not a just to be concerned about this
in principle, but we've gotta be responsible
I guess.
I believe Brianna joy gray misspoke, although
she's been doing a lot of misspeaking lately.
I don't know, but this is starting to get
ugly on multiple sides.
It is not, there's nothing wrong with believing
that Bernie should do what he promised to
do, which he now says he's not going to do.
He should do it.
Michael Bloomberg should put out his records.
We should get full disclosure from Joe Biden
and we actually may have close to two that
from Joe Biden.
Joe Biden's put out quite a bit.
Just put out the records guys.
That's all.
And then vote for whoever you agree with most
on the issues.
For me, it's Bernie.
It's very simple, but I still want to see
that full medical record.